eine petition das ist ein ersuchen eine
bitte liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sie
wissen dass die meisten die ich hier
sehe wissen von was ich spreche
in unserer verfassung ist das grundrecht
verankert dass sich jedermann egal
welchen alters oder welcher
staatsangehörigkeit damit an die
zuständigen stellen und an die
volksvertretung wenden kann für die
behandlung der an den bundestag
gerichtet in bitten zur
bundesgesetzgebung und zu problemen mit
bundesbehörde ist der petitionsausschuss
zuständig die bestellung dieses
ausschusses ist seit 1975 im grundgesetz
bestimmt und der petitionsausschuss ist
verpflichtet die petitionen anzunehmen
sie sorgfältig zu prüfen und sie zu
bescheiden
funktionieren würde das alles und diese
arbeit allerdings nicht ohne unsere
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
den mitarbeitern des ausschuss dienstes
die oft als erste den unmut zu spüren
bekommen und viel zu selten für ihren
wichtigen beitrag gewürdigt worden
deswegen auch hier nochmals neben dem
applaus main an meiner stelle herzlichen
dank ohne die wäre unser gemeinwesen um
ein vielfaches ärmer
bedanken möchte ich mich aber auch am
anfang bei allen mitgliedern des
petitionsausschusses
die kollegiale zusammenarbeit die wir
nach wie vor pflegen ist nicht
selbstverständlich und im zuge dessen
auf meine besten genesungswünsche an den
obmann der unions-fraktion den kollegen
gero storjohann er wird sehr vermisst
und nun zum eigentlichen anlass der
debatte jedes jahr liegt der ausschuss
dem deutschen bundestag seinen
tätigkeitsbericht für das jahr 2021 war
neben der anderen corona pandemie
geprägt vom wechsel der wahlperiode die
letzte sitzung des petitionsausschusses
der 19 wahlperiode fand am 16 am 6
september
2000 23 statt und bereits am 11 november
2021 erfolgte die konstituierende
sitzung des petitionsausschusses der
zwanzigster wahlperiode welcher gemäß
einsetzung beschluss zunächst nur mit 19
mitgliedern und es freut mich jetzt sehr
frau präsidentin unter ihrem vorsitz
frau mag was damals tagte
seit dem 15 dezember besteht der
ausschuss nun aus 31 ordentlichen den
stellvertretenden mitgliedern und
seitdem darf ich diesen ausschuss leiten
ich möchte ein paar fakten aus dem
berichtsjahr mit dem bei ein paar fakten
beginnen wir hatten im jahr
2021 helft
1667 petition beim petitionsausschuss
das ist ein bisschen weniger als 2020
gerechnet auf die werktage dieses jahres
etwas 46 petitionen pro tag
dabei gingen
4860 und somit etwa 42 prozent aller
eingaben auf elektronische wege über das
petitions portal im internet ein und
mittlerweile haben wir vier millionen
registrierte nutzerinnen und nutzer
damit ist es petitions portal das
erfolgreichste internetangebot des
deutschen bundestages
es bietet uns die möglichkeit den
ausschuss petitionen auf einfachen
elektronischen weg zu übermitteln und
die öffentliche petitionen online zu
unterstützen und zu diskutieren und
viele besucherinnen und besucher fanden
ihren weg tatsächlich über petitions
plattform des ausschusses über den
direkten zugang über suchmaschinen und
über nachrichtenportale was zu beachten
ist ein großer zulauf immerhin 26
prozent der nutzerinnen und nutzer wurde
wieder über soziale netzwerke
verzeichnet die petentin und beenden
immer öfter nutzen um auf unsere
petition speditionen hinzuweisen auch
eigens geschaffene webseiten für
informationen zu veröffentlichen
anliegen gewinnen immer mehr an
bedeutung und im berichtszeitraum haben
330.000 nutzerinnen und nutzer im portal
des petitionsausschusses sich neu
registriert um eine petition
einzureichen im petitions forum zu
diskutieren oder petitionen durch eine
mit zeichnung zu unterstützen
neben der petitionen mit vorschlägen zur
gesetzgebung widmet sich der
petitionsausschuss ebenso den sorgen und
nöten der bürgerinnen und bürger die den
ausschuss im einzelfall um unterstützung
baten die bearbeitung solcher
persönliche anliegen machte für den
ausschuss mit rund 62 prozent auch im
jahr
2021 wieder mehr als die hälfte seiner
arbeit aus viele dieser petition
entstanden nicht unerwartet im zeichen
der korona bande und haben wir uns die
bandbreite der auswirkung dieser
pandemie auch noch einmal aufgezeigt
dabei ging es zb um soforthilfen für
studierende die oft den wegfall eines
nebenjobs in finanzielle schwierigkeiten
geraten sind oder um wirtschaftliche
hilfen für die kultur und medien branche
die schwer von der pandemie getroffen
wurde der petitionsausschuss
unterstützte nachdrücklich schnelle und
unbürokratische hilfe
außerdem konnten wir anfragen von
petentin und petenten bereits im vorfeld
des parlamentarischen verfahrens
abgeschlossen werden denn häufig
bewirkten stellungnahme ersuchen des
petitionsausschusses bei den staatlichen
stellen eine gründliche abwägung des
sachverhalts und manchmal war das finden
von lösungswegen aber leider auch
kompliziert hier waren beispielsweise
ausführliche gespräche der
berichterstattung berichterstatter unter
beteiligung von vertreterinnen und
vertretern der bundesregierung hilfreich
im berichtsjahr fanden elfter richter
stand der gespräche zu themen wie
beispielsweise
patientenrechte energieversorgung
beamtenrecht immer wieder ein thema was
uns
beschäftigt arbeitsschutz der
straßenverkehrsordnung und vor allem
vielen visa-angelegenheiten statt auch
wenn die ortsbesichtigungen die wir in
der regel ausführen wegen der pandemie
nicht
ausgeführt werden konnten sind wir neue
wege gegangen haben mit video und
drohnen aufnahmen und einen einblick
verschafft um gemeinsam uns die
situation vor augen zu halten und
lösungen herbeizuführen
abschließend behandelt hat der ausschuss
dann tatsächlich über 12.000 eingaben
davon wurden 368 petitionen zur
einzelberatung aufgerufen etwa ein
viertel der zuschriften betraf den
zuständigkeit des bundesministeriums für
gesundheit welches auch natürlich
letztes jahr den ersten platz hatte
dieses wie bereits eingangs erwähnt
insbesonders der den zahlreichen
eingaben im zusammenhang mit der korona
fanden gegründet auf dem zweiten platz
mit deutlichem abstand das
bundesministerium der justiz mit etwa 13
und dann auf platz drei des
bundesministerium des inneren mit knapp
12 prozent
der petitionsausschuss bietet seit
gründung der bundesrepublik die
schnittstelle zwischen dem bundestag und
seinem souverän den bürgerinnen und
bürgern die menschen sehen im
petitionsausschuss oft als letzte
möglichkeit hilfe und unterstützung zu
erfahren wenn man bedenkt dass manche
probleme die zunächst klein scheinen für
viele betroffene enorme auswirkungen auf
ihre lebensumstände haben dann ist der
petitionsausschuss als rettungs instanz
in der not gesehen wird bestätigt dass
einmal mehr die notwendigkeit und die
bedeutung dieses ausschusses und nicht
auf allen danken die jahr tatkräftig
mitarbeiten
ich habe eben seinen petitionen ein
wichtiger gradmesser der umsetzung von
gesetzen sie zeigen uns parlamentariern
wo es unstimmigkeiten gibt und wo
handlungsbedarf besteht
die entscheidungen des ausschusses sind
keine gerichtsurteile wir können
letztendlich nur empfehlungen
aussprechen
oft führen diese aber dazu dass
entscheidungen gesetze und regeln
überdacht und so für das allgemeinwohl
verträgliche lösungen gefunden werden
und sollte der petentin oder den
petenten nicht zu dem gewünschten
ergebnis verholfen werden versucht der
petitionsausschuss zu helfen immer den
betroffenen die entscheidungen der
behörden erklärt und besser verständlich
macht
gleichzeitig liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen dürfen wir uns nicht ausruhen
wer verhandelt erstattet auch der
petitionsausschuss
muss und wird die technische
möglichkeiten die sich ihnen heutzutage
bieten nutzen um den bürgerinnen und
bürgern eine niedrige schwelle und
transparente möglichkeit zu bieten sich
in politische prozesse einzubringen und
ihre sorgen und nöte gehör zu
verschaffen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen für mich ist es eine große ehre
für diesen wichtigen ausschuss dem
bindeglied zwischen dem souverän und im
parlament als wohl bedeutendes
instrument der direkten demokratie als
vorsitzender tätig zu sein herzlichen
dank für die aktion
matthias stamm viebig die vorsitzende
des petitionsausschusses mit ihrem
berichte und jetzt geht es hier
natürlich mit der aussprache weiter
erste rednerin wird sein corinna rüffer
die für die fraktion bündnis 90/die
grünen obfrau im petitionsausschuss ist
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
liebe martina stamm viebig hoch
geschätzte vorsitzende des ausschusses
ich möchte mich an der stelle
ausdrücklich deinem dank an den
ausschuss dienst anschließen dem es
überhaupt nichts hinzuzufügen ohne
diesen ausschuss dienst wäre der
ausschuss nichts und das verdient ein
richtigen
applaus kolleginnen und kollegen
viele menschen haben den eindruck dass
sie die abgeordneten des bundestages
kaum erreichen und man fragt sich warum
eigentlich wir alle bieten sprechstunden
an und bemühen uns zumeist redlich darum
die probleme die uns dort begegnen auch
tatsächlich zu lösen aber offensichtlich
reicht das nicht die mütter und väter
unseres grundgesetzes waren kluge leute
das wird sicher niemand bestreiten sie
haben daran gedacht in artikel 17 im
prinzip den petitionsausschuss zu
verankern und sie haben gut daran getan
petitionen sind wichtig und sie wirken
egal ob es um einen falsch berechneten
rentenbescheid geht sich jemand über
mangelnde unterstützung bei der
beruflichen rehabilitation beschwert
oder das parlament zu einer
tiefgreifenden reformen aufgefordert
wird um im angesicht einer alternden
gesellschaft auch zukünftig eine pflege
in würde zu gewährleisten und fast immer
sind petitionen präzise hinweise auf
bestehende problemlagen und oft
beinhalten sie auch präzise vorschläge
wie der gesetzgeber also wir sie lösen
wir sind gut beraten ganz genau
hinzuhören und unsere petentin als
partner bei der entwicklung einer
zukunftsfähigen gesellschaft
wahrzunehmen
kommunikation auf augenhöhe mit
bürgerinnen mit potenten es wichtig vor
allem angesichts einer zunehmenden
gesellschaftlichen polarisierung und ja
der petitionsausschuss sein großes
politisches potenzial in den letzten
jahren ehrlich gesagt leider nicht
genutzt und sich auf seine aus unserer
sicht über kommende rolle als
kummerkasten der nation wenn hat loos
hat das gestern so formuliert in der
bundespressekonferenz bei der übergabe
des berichtes wir halten diese
perspektive tatsächlich für über kommen
und warum hat der ausschuss sich nicht
zeitgemäß weiterentwickelt ich meine das
hat mit der jahrelang unionsmehrheit
tatsächlich zu tun die sich geweigert
hat das instrument als politisches
instrument tatsächlich auch zu nutzen
und das petitionswesen
dementsprechend zu stärken und
vielleicht darf man an dieser stelle
auch mal die kritische frage stellen ob
sozusagen die immer größere bedeutung
von privaten plattformen auch damit
etwas zu tun haben könnte ich rege zur
diskussion an liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich wollte eigentlich eine
petition an dieser stelle noch mehr in
den blick nehmen die sehr viel kraft
entwickelt hat ich will sie zumindest
kurz ansprechen die von frau lechleiter
leuchten dort nämlich stoppt die
blockade der krankenkassen bei der
versorgung schwerstbehinderter kinder
und erwachsener diese tolle frau und
mutter hat unter anderem ein
schwerstbehindertes wunderbares kind
will ich an dieser stelle hinzufügen und
sie hat es satt statt zeit mit ihren
kindern zu verbringen aktenordner mit
der papier gewordenen auseinandersetzung
mit krankenkassen und medizinischen
dienst zu befüllen sie hat sich
entschieden den kampf gegen diese
kafkaeske bürokratie aufzunehmen und
sich damit nicht nur für ihre eigene
familie sondern für ganz viele menschen
in diesem land einzusetzen
sie hat es nicht nur geschafft ein
netzwerk zu schaffen ja sondern sie hat
auch in den koalitionsvertrag geschafft
und ich bin ganz sicher dass wir in
diesem ausschuss aber nicht nur in
diesem ausschuss über die problemlage
von familien mit behinderten kindern
auch weiterhin zu reden haben würden
aber ehrlich gesagt andreas mattfeldt
mir pressiert es akut an einer anderen
stelle ich habe gestern abends da der
pressemitteilung anlässlich der übergabe
unseres jahresberichts an die
bundestagspräsidentin gelesen und du
schreibst darin und ich frage allen
ernstes die ampel koalition habe gleich
nach der bundestagswahl angefangen
parteipolitisch zu taktieren mein lieber
scholli
entweder es macht sich bei dir eine
hoffentlich zeitlich begrenzte form von
gedächtnisstörungen bemerkbar macht hier
bewusst den bock zum gärtner hast du
wirklich nicht bemerkt wie sich die
kultur der arbeit in diesem ausschuss
mit dem regierungswechsel geändert hat
ich sitze wöchentlich damit den kollegen
von der fdp von der fdp mit der
vorsitzenden zusammen ja und ich weiß
was für eine kultur wie etablieren
wollen du weißt dass weil du jeden
mittwoch in diesem ausschuss bist wir
sind dabei dieses petitionsrecht auf
neue füße zu stellen ist transparenter
zu machen barrierefreier zugänglicher
für alle menschen in diesem land ihr
seid herzlich eingeladen damit dazu
beizutragen aber bitte hört auf eurer
seite mit dieser tag parteipolitischen
taktiererei das hat das petitionswesen
dieses landes nicht verdient herzlichen
dank
deutliche worte an die kollegen aus der
opposition von corinna rüffer obfrau im
petitionsausschuss für bündnis 90 die
grünen im deutschen bundestag und die
opposition kann nun antworten andreas
mattfeldt für die unionsfraktion
präsidentin meine sehr geehrten damen
und ja
ich habe es gehört der
petitionsausschuss der ist in den
vergangenen monaten in einer ganz neuen
konstellation gestartet und ich darf das
sagen ich freue mich besonders dass
wieder zahlreiche neue kolleginnen und
kollegen lust auf dieses so wichtige
petitionswesen bauausschuss bekommen
haben und sehr geehrte frau vorsitzende
liebe martina stand fibig ich darf auch
ihnen danken dass sie die verantwortung
mit dem ausschuss vorsitzt für uns alle
hier übernommen haben
das denkt sich doch oder deshalb ist es
ja auch einstimmig erfolgt meine damit
hören aber die wichtigkeit des
petitionsausschusses die wird eben nicht
nur durch seine verankerung im
grundgesetz deutlich an allen die zahlen
der eingaben die sprechen für sich im
vergangenen jahr ist mit elf
petitions war sie haben es gesagt ein
leichter rückgang zu verzeichnen ich
möchte aber weil ich 13 jahre diesem
ausschuss angehören betonen dass dies
überhaupt nicht ungewöhnlich ist wir
haben immer auf und ab so der
petitionsausschuss des eben immer auch
ein stimmungsbarometer in der
bevölkerung an der rückgang sondern
rückgang der kann auch mal bedeuten dass
die menschen im berichtszeitraum
zufrieden mit ihrer regierung waren und
frau kollegin river der jahresbericht
der betrifft ja noch die zeit der großen
koalition und es waren wir einfach mal
ganz entspannt und bisschen ruhiger ab
wie sich die eingaben unter der ampel
hier entwickeln werden ich muss aber
auch ganz deutlich sagen dass eben der
staat in dieser wahlperiode für den
ausschuss irgendwie schlichtweg so einen
stotter start war es war schon etwas
seltsam dass die ampel aus der wahl vom
vorsitz und stellvertretung das ist
eigentlich ein ganz normaler formeller
akt sogar zwei termine gemacht hat und
in dieser zeit hätten wir viele
petitionen
abschließen können und sie kommen zur
parteipolitik frau eva und da war ich
irritiert es ist sehr seltsam gewesen
übrigens habe ich das in 13 jahren das
zu ihrer kultur zu ihrer kultur des
neuanfangs noch nie erlebt dass sie eine
petition angehalten habe die ihnen nicht
passt weil sie ein neues wolfsmanagement
gefordert hat diese petition hat vor
allem auch die sorge die sorgen der
weide tierhalter berücksichtigt und der
ausschuss hatte hier bereits das höchste
fifa das höchste votum abgegeben und an
die die regierung übergeben und die
petition die befand sich bereits auf dem
weg hier zu uns ins plenum und wurde von
ihnen von der ampel ganz besonders von
ihnen von den grünen gestoppt dass es im
vorfeld noch nie dagewesen
und wie die fdp lieber kollege manfred
obenhausen die mit ganz großen
ankündigungen beim thema wurst und
wahlkampf dies vereinbaren kann dass es
mir schlichtweg schleierhaft ich fordere
sie wirklich auf die fdp wenn sie bei
den bauern nicht komplett ihre
glaubwürdigkeit verlieren wollen bringen
sie diese petition umgehend hier wieder
zurück ins plenum behandeln sie
und meine damen und herren ich
möchte an dieser stelle bürgerinnen und
bürger ermutigen ermutigen petitionen
direkt an den bundestag einzureichen
viele bürger wissen schlichtweg nicht
dass sie zum teil immer zahlreicher
werdenden internet portale manche haben
auch das englische wort britischen in
ihrem titel mit uns mit dem original
schlichtweg gar nichts zu tun haben und
leider kommt diese sicherlich häufig
auch gut gemeinten eingaben eben nicht
bei uns im bundestag an es handelt sich
hier häufig und kampagnenorientierte und
politisch motivierte seiten deren
finanzierung völlig unklar und zum teil
auch intransparent ist und deshalb immer
und wieder mein rat an die bürger wenn
sie wirklich etwas
verändern wollen wenn sie gute ideen
haben reichen sie eine petition an den
deutschen bundestag ein dabei ist es uns
im petitionsausschuss vollkommen egal ob
sie das als einzelperson oder mit ganz
vielen mit zeichnungen machen sie können
bei uns im petitionsausschuss sicher
sein dass jede position
sorgfältig geprüft bearbeitet und die
bürgerinnen und bürger auch eine
qualifizierte antwort erreichen und das
bekommen sie bei den privaten portalen
eben nicht und
meine damen und herren immer wieder
diskutieren wir natürlich über
änderungen petitionswesen das ist auch
wichtig viel wichtiger ist aber dass wir
die dauer der petitionsverfahren
verkürzen ich bin überzeugt dass die
lang geforderte einführung der digitalen
petitions akte und noch schneller und
noch effektiver werden lässt damit die
petenten nord fixer eine antwort
bekommen und meine damen und herren toll
wäre es auch wenn der petitionsausschuss
noch einfacher für die menschen
erreichbar ist hierfür muss ganz ganz
dringend das e petition portal erneuert
werden da sind wir uns
fraktionsübergreifend alle einigt in der
heutigen zeit muss es eben
selbstverständlich sein dass die
petitionen auch über unsere bundestag
sap eingereicht werden können wir sind
dabei ich hoffe es geht schneller als es
uns zuvor angekündigt wird und im
übrigen darf ich an dieser stelle frau
präsidentin
ausdrücklich dafür werben dass unser
petitionsausschuss endlich endlich einen
eigenen sitzungssaal im hause bekommt um
die anerkennung unserer arbeit und die
ideen der bürgerinnen und bürger
angemessen zu würdigen seit jahren
warten wir schon darauf jeder in diesem
haus alle fraktionen dokumentieren die
wichtigkeit des petitionsausschusses
aber wenn es um taten gehen sehen wir da
leider sehr wenig übrigens auch unter
anderen konstellationen in diesem haus
ich würde mir wünschen wenn wir das in
dieser legislaturperiode hinbekommen
meine damen und herren lassen sich
abschließend noch danke sagen danke
sagen bei unserem ausschuss dienst aber
vor allen dingen auch bei unseren
mitarbeitern in den abgeordneten und
fraktions büros ohne sie herr doktor
passwort im ausschuss dienst und die
vielen mitarbeiter die uns hier zu
arbeiten wäre die arbeit definitiv nicht
zu bewerkstelligen gut dass wir euch
haben herzlichen dank
andreas mattfeldt war das und schon bei
den ersten rednern ist aufgefallen wie
breit die themen sind unter anderem ging
es hier um wolfs politik aber natürlich
war auch energieversorgung beamtenrecht
arbeitsschutz und straßenverkehrsordnung
ein thema das größte thema bei den
petition 20 21 die korona panik
damen und herren das freut mich wirklich
sehr dass ich auch dieses jahr wieder
für die fdp wollte zum jahresbericht des
petitionsausschuss hier sagen darf
allein die tatsache dass es einen
solchen bericht gibt unterscheidet uns
von anderen
ausschüssen denn nur der trägt er einen
jahresbericht vor das hängt natürlich
eine koalition
zu kompromissen die wir im
koalitionsvertrag
eigentlich gar nicht ausgehandelt hat
aber ob wir das als ampel dann die
zukunft gut machen wie wir uns das
vorgenommen haben das haben wir uns
werden wir dann bei der nächsten
vorstellung des jahresberichtes sehen
und übernächsten jahr werden wir dann
wahrscheinlich hervorragende ergebnisse
bekommen bisher funktioniert es
jedenfalls sehr sehr gut
aber aber es ist eine der lehren aus den
letzten jahren dass die
kompromissfindung und entscheidungs
dauer schneller werden kann und muss und
lieber andreas mattfeldt ich hätte es
nicht gesagt aber jetzt muss ich sagen
die letzte regierung hat petitionen über
jahre liegen lassen und weil sie sich
nicht einigen konnten und
auch die werden wir jetzt handeln und
verarbeiten
das wird jetzt zügig abgearbeitet in den
vergangenen jahren wurden elf
1667 petitionen eingereicht und von
denen haben wir im ausschuss
diskutiert und abgestimmt die übrigen
konnten übrigens und das weiß man
eigentlich nicht weiß nicht nur außen
getragen wird durch die arbeit der
berichterstatter und berichterstatterin
bearbeitet und entschieden werden und
das ist eine besonderheit des
petitionsausschusses dass nicht nur die
ordentlichen mitglieder sondern auch die
stellvertretenden mitglieder themen
bearbeiten und entscheiden müssen und
können immer gut vorbereitet durch die
bundestagsverwaltung daher möchte ich an
dieser stelle auch einmal um einen
applaus für die fleißigen mitarbeiter
des ausschuss dienstes aber auch für
unsere mitarbeiter in den teams werben
die haben das wirklich verdient
die zahl der im letzten jahr in den
ausschusssitzungen
behandelten petitionen ist leider
teilweise zurückgegangen das ist
durchaus ein problem was wir haben dann
in wahljahren fehlen uns tatsächlich
fast fünf monate mit sitzungswochen die
wir dann jetzt aufholen müssen ich hoffe
das bekommen wir hin der
petitionsausschuss soll und will ein
besonderes bürgernahes über bürgernahe
ausschuss seien daher wäre es war es
sehr bedauerlich dass wir corona bedingt
unsere verschiedenen messeauftritte und
bürger sprechen und absagen mussten und
ich freue mich wahnsinnig darüber dass
diese direkte art der
öffentlichkeitsarbeit des parlaments
jetzt wieder möglich ist und auch
genutzt wird eine besondere art der
kontaktaufnahme wir haben es gehört ist
das internetportal des
petitionsausschusses auf dem petition
eingereicht diskutiert und mitgezeichnet
werden können es ist auch das haben wir
schon gehört das meistgenutzte
internetangebot des deutschen
bundestages und damit ein besonderes
heraus stellung heraus
engels schild unseres parlaments meine
damen und herren ich möchte noch gern
mal auf unsere plattform hinweisen ich
mache einfach mal werbung dafür
epetition punkt bundestag.de dort finden
sie alle hinweise gehen sie einfach mal
drauf es ist wichtig dass wir in dieser
legislatur allerdings die erneuerung
unserer petitions plattform angegangen
sind und hoffentlich auch erfolgreich
abschließen werden denn sie muss den
schweren spagat zwischen einfacher und
niederschwelliger bedienung einerseits
und einer sehr hohen sicherheits
andererseits schaffen mangel der
sicherheit würde die petitions plattform
zum einfallstor für demokratie feinde
machen die ersten versuche haben wir in
den letzten jahren beobachten können ich
könnte jetzt eine ganze reihe von
petitionen nennen die ich inhaltlich der
spannenden gefunden habe verbesserungen
der korona hilfe zum beispiel weil
kultur medienbranche aber in anderen
wirtschaftszweigen aufnahme
diplomatischer beziehungen mit taiwan
zwangsadoption in der ddr anerkennung
der völkermorde an den jesiden oder bei
holodomor kennzeichnung von
arzneimitteln und viele viele mehr aber
lesen sie doch einfach mal uns ein
jahresbericht der ist auf der seite des
bundestags zu finden da wir hier über
die arbeit des vergangenen jahres reden
möchte ich zum abschluss die gelegenheit
nutzen mich auch einmal bei marion wendt
im ausschuss vorsitzenden der letzten
wahlperiode für die sehr gute und
kollegiale zusammenarbeit bedanken ich
hoffe maryam maryam du verfolgst die
rede aber auch die besten grüße an gero
storjohann der uns sehr fehlt
und ganz zum schluss möchte ich noch
mich ganz herzlich bei der neuen
vorsitzenden martina stand viebig
bedanken für ihre wirklich hervorragende
arbeit alles gute für diese wahlperiode
wünschen der einstieg ist waren sie
nicht gut gelungen ich hoffe es geht
weiter so auch eine weiterhin gute
zusammenarbeit im sinne der patientinnen
und der petentin vielen dank
manfred vonhausen war das für die fdp
nächster redner ist dirk brandes ob man
im petitionsausschuss für die fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten kollegen
[Musik]
gestalten auch sie mir zu beginn mich
ganz herzlich bei den mitarbeitern des
ausschuss dienstes zu bedanken ohne sie
liebe mitarbeiter wäre in der tat wie
meine vorredner das auch schon gesagt
haben die ganze arbeit definitiv nicht
zu bewältigen
aber nun zu ihnen meine lieben kollegen
unsere demokratie funktioniert nicht
ohne die menschen da draußen und frau
stamm viel ich sie haben es ihm gesagt
der petitionsausschuss ist ein
bindeglied zwischen den bürgern dieses
landes und dem parlament und wenn es
nach mir geht sollte das noch viel mehr
werden das möchte ich kurz ausführen
schade ist nicht dass die alte fraktion
in einer art demokratie demokratischen
traumtänzer balletts die bedürfnisse der
menschen oft ignorieren die als afd
setzen wir das auf die tagesordnung was
wir in den letzten jahren ihr versorgt
haben wir möchten mehr direkte
demokratie wagen deswegen lautet unsere
zentrale forderung zu den wichtigen
fragen in deutschland und in europa muss
endlich volksabstimmungen nach schweizer
vorbild geben meine kollegen damit haben
dass das außer mit meiner eigenen
fraktion nicht zu machen ist zeigen sie
stets eindrucksvoll und zur vollsten
zufriedenheit ihrer lobbyisten unter
anderem aus den bereichen pharma nahrung
und neuerdings auch mit grüner
zustimmung der rüstungsindustrie
wir hingegen wollen die instrumente
stärken die es ermöglichen dem bürger
mehr einflussnahme auf die politische
willensbildung zu geben dazu wollen wir
den petitionsausschuss des deutschen
bundestages zu einem werkzeug direkter
demokratie machen dafür müssen wir
endlich anfangen die bestehenden
grundsätze zu überarbeiten seien wir
doch ehrlich wie sie die realität denn
aktuell aus politische petition landen
nach den stellungnahmen des zuständigen
ministeriums bei den abgeordneten zur
berichterstattung im petitionsausschuss
wird dann entschieden ob sie diese
anliegen für unterstützenswert halten
das ist aber immer nur dann der fall
wenn das ziel der petition ohnehin schon
in ihrem koalitionsvertrag vereinbart
wurde so hatte unterm strich keine der
6326 parlamentarisch beraten der
petition im ausschuss je eine chance zu
bestehen wenn sie regierungs kritische
position zum inhalt hat
der rückgang der petition oder an
petition betrifft im übrigen jedes
einzelne ressorts bis auf eine sehr
prägnante ausnahme die zahl der petition
an das bundesministerium für gesundheit
stieg um 14,4 prozent
na klar ist dass bush und ich sage ihnen
auch warum das so ist das sind
mittlerweile ein viertel aller eingaben
und das ist genau der bereich in dem die
individuellen freiheitsrechte der bürger
von ihnen mit füßen getreten worden sind
in das jahr oder in den letzten beiden
jahren und gegen diesen verlust an
freiheit wendeten sich nicht nur die
vielen millionen an demonstranten auf
der straße sondern auch viele petenten
berücksichtigung fanden ihre interessen
leider nicht oder wenig anderes beispiel
aus dem pflegewesen im februar 2021 gab
es für eine petition immerhin
355.000 unterzeichner in dieser wurde
die verbesserung der arbeitsbedingungen
für pflegekräfte gefordert und was
machen sie vom politisch
gleichgeschalteten lockt der schon
länger hier sitzenden ich sage es in
sich die impfpflicht ein für das
pflegepersonal
pflichtimpfung sind für mich persönlich
eine ganz merkwürdige form von dank für
die menschen die sie monate zuvor als
helden der korona krise bezeichnet haben
meine damen und herren
eigenen drittel aller deutschen haben
inzwischen das gefühl sie leben in einer
scheindemokratie das ist nicht nur die
meinung der afg fraktion das ist eine
aus einer veröffentlichten umfrage des
allensbach-instituts und das halte ich
persönlich für alarmieren
wie möchte die ampel jetzt darauf
reagieren wird unsere innenministerin
jetzt die haldenwang truppe ermutigen 30
prozent der bevölkerung wegen
delegitimierung des staates zu
rechtsextremen verdachtsfällen zu
erklären oder machen wir lieber
folgendes wir ermöglichen den menschen
endlich mehr
mitspracherechte und das petitionsrecht
muss dahingehend reformiert werden dass
wir es in patenten ermöglichen dass ab
einem bestimmten quorum das anliegen als
tagesordnungspunkte hier in unserer
plenum erreicht was würde das für die
bürger bedeuten und was würde das für
sie bedeutet schauen sie mal wir führen
hier regelmäßig debatten durch über die
menschenrechtslage in 194 ländern der
welt plötzlich diskutierten wir zwei
stunden über die sitzordnung dieses
hauses meine damen und herren
warum dann nicht mal über einen
bürgeranliegen die in massenpetition
geäußert werden das wäre doch mal eine
maßnahme das wäre schon mal ein kleines
erstes mittel gegen die grassierende
politikverdrossenheit
in diesem land meine damen und herren
meine damen und herren unser volk ist
mündig wagen wir endlich mehr direkte
demokratie
ich danke
[Applaus]
und für die spd fraktion hat das wort
der kollege iberia
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen der demokratischen
fraktionen sehr geehrte petentin liebe
zuschauer brandes menschen die hier
vokabeln gleichstellung oder eine
gleichschaltung meinte tschuldigung
benutzen zeigen doch welch geistes kind
sie sind und zum thema inflation
wir haben absichtlich diese petition
öffentlich beraten unserer vor der
entscheidung über eine pflicht das haben
wir absichtlich gemacht weil es uns
genau darum gehen diese argumente zu
hören also dann wird bei der wahl klar
[Applaus]
liebe kollegen steht heute vor der
herausforderung sagt obmann über den
jahresbericht petitionen zu sprechen in
der der eine zeit behandelt in der ich
noch gar kein abgeordneter waren daher
sehe ich meine aufgabe darin aus dem
vorliegenden bericht schlüsse für die
zukunft zu ziehen
2020 behandelte der ausschuss 14.000 134
petition 2021 waren es auch elf
1667 und damit deutlich weniger trotzdem
sprechen wir hier von immerhin 46
petitionen pro werktag im jahre 2021 an
dieser stelle richtig mit dem dank an
den ausschüssen uns im namen der
spd-fraktion natürlich anschließen ohne
sie die uns immer zur seite stehen
werden wir glaube ich nicht zur
handlungsfähig wie es im ausschuss sind
deswegen herzlichen dank nochmal
und natürlich jedoch unser dank unserer
ausschuss vorsitzende martina stand viel
ich liebe martina du reitest diesen
ausschuss mit ruhe sachlichkeit und
großer kompetenz und ich kann versichern
das ist sehr auffällt wenn du nicht da
bist
der angesprochene rückgang der
eingegangenen positionen zwischen den
jahren 2020 und 2021 fed deutlich auf
aber es ist die zahlen der vorhandene
jahre einmal ansieht bemerkt schnell
dass schwankungen nichts ungewöhnliches
sind und die zahlen auf das niveau von
2000 bis 17 zurückgegangen sind diese
entwicklungen es wird trotzdem genau im
auge behalten und uns fragen was die
gründe dafür sind erfreulich ist die
anzahl der online einreichung die 2021
42 prozent aller petitionen ausmachten
allein die
330.000 neuanmeldungen auf unserer
plattform sprechen bände obwohl die zahl
auch im vergleich zu 2020 fast halbiert
hat wichtig ist dass 26 prozent aller
nutzer in ihren weg auf die seite des
petitionsausschusses über social media
kanäle gefunden haben und wir sollten
wir einen fokus darauf legen um mehr
öffentlichkeit für petitionen zu
erreichen das ist gut und richtig dass
wir im ausschuss einstimmig den umbau
und die modernisierung unserer eigenen
plattform zu bestimmt haben wir haben
einen großen instrumente tasten um auf
die anliegen der petenten eingehen zu
können von termin vor ort
berichterstatter gesprächen mit der
bundesregierung bis hin zu verschiedenen
überweisungs alternativen der
petitionsausschuss hat viele
möglichkeiten und wir sollten sie in
zukunft stärker nutzen
aber das kann nur der anfang sein von
einer reform des petitionsrecht es hin
zu einem stärkeren instrument der
bürgerbeteiligung
und das kann uns als ampel vorgenommen
das werden wir jetzt ampel auch umsetze
und ich lade explizit die opposition
dazu ein sich daran zu beteiligen
petition liegen absolut im trend das
kann jeder erfahren dass ich die
klickzahlen auf den privaten plattform
einmal genauer ansieht 50.000 mit
zeichnungen und mehr haben dort keine
seltenheit
bei uns waren es im jahr 2021 ganze 55
von mehr als 11.000 petition dieses
quorum erreicht hatten das sind rund 0,5
prozent aller petitionen fairness halber
muss man anmerken dass für 636
petitionen veröffentlicht wurden und
somit wort mit bezeichnet werden konnten
trotzdem sprechen wir hier nur von 0,8
prozent aller möglichen petition die
öffentlich behandelt wurden das ist aus
meiner sicht zu wenige zu wenig petition
die veröffentlicht wurden zu wenig
petitionen die das quorum erreicht haben
und zu wenig petitionen die ohne das
erreichen des forums öffentlich
behandelt wurden denn das erreichen des
quorums ist bekanntlich keine pflicht
für eine öffentliche behandlung und den
kolleginnen und kollegen in der pandemie
zeit es wurde angesprochen waren 25
prozent der petitionen an das
gesundheitsministerium gerichtet oder
zumindest im
zuständigkeitsbereich dieses hauses wir
sehen also dass der petitionsausschuss
ein seismograph für die
gesellschaftliche realität dieses landes
ist aus den vorgelegten zahlen er gibt
es ja im reformbedarf das petitionswesen
wenn edition als instrument der
bürgerbeteiligung gewünscht sind dann
muss es leichter werden sie einzureichen
sie zu veröffentlichen und auch mit zu
zeichnen bleibt der petitionsausschuss
eine art nationaler kummerkasten und das
ist mir persönlich zu wenig
machen wir uns nichts vor bestehen in
einer konkurrenz um aufmerksamkeit zu
den großen kampagnen plattform obwohl
unser ausschuss die einzige plattform
für bürger innen ist die eine
veränderung im sinne einer petition
herbeiführen kann wir wollen dass
petitions wir wollen dass der
petitionsausschuss nicht nur in
politischen sonntagsreden aufgrund
seiner verfassung seines verfassungsrang
ausgelobt wird als ampel wollen wir dass
der ausschuss endlich die stellung zu
den einfluss erhält die ihm aufgrund
seines alters auch zu stehen
darüber hinaus stand mir
sozialdemokraten schon seit langem vor
dem petitionswesen durch eine
beauftragte person auch in der regierung
ein gesicht zu geben einzelne
bundesländer haben hier vergleichbare
ombudsstellen schon geschaffen und damit
gute erfahrungen gemacht dies lässt sich
auf bundesebene auf das petitionswesen
gut übersetzen so schaffen wir vertrauen
bei den bürgerinnen und bürgern so
unterstreichen wir auch die bedeutung
die petition im politischen betrieb
haben abschließend müssen wir uns selbst
eingestehen dass wir in der
bearbeitungszeit schneller werden müssen
aber nach kurzer zeit ein sprecher der
sozialdemokraten im petitionsausschuss
weiß ich dass petition oft viele leute
jahre liegen meistens weil es keine
politische einigung gibt gerade in
zeiten der großen koalition war das
leider viel zu oft der fall
die einen sagen so die anderen so das
darf nicht so sein denn so schaffen wir
nicht mehr partizipation sondern fördern
politikverdrossen kann zusammen
da hatten sie können
zusammenfassen zeigt der bericht
deutlich es gibt viel zu tun es gibt
viel potenzial also packendes gemeinsam
an herzlichen dank
der bundestag diskutiert über den
tätigkeitsbericht des
petitionsausschusses 20 21 und sie sehen
ist schon im bild wir erwarten auch die
pressekonferenz der
kommissionspräsidentin ursula von der
leyen und den präsidenten des
europäischen rats charme michelle immer
mit dem treffen der staats und
regierungschefs der eu mit den sechs
westbalkan in ländern zu den
beitrittsperspektive in die eu solange
bleiben wir aber natürlich noch in der
debatte
der bericht des petitionsausschusses ist
legislatur übergreift der umfasst also
auch für mich nur einen kleinen teil
meiner eigenen tätigkeit im
petitionsausschuss
dieser ausschuss ist besonders zum einen
durch seine seinen verfassungsrang zum
anderen weil er der ausschuss ist der
die größte nähe zu den bürgern im
parlamentarischen geschäft zulässt wir
erfahren durch die petition ungefiltert
und direkt die auswirkungen unseres
gesetzgeberischen handelns dies gelingt
nur gemeinsam mit den mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeitern des ausschuss dienstes
und ich kann jetzt sagen dass es im
oktober letzten jahres war ich selbst
referentin beim bürgerbeauftragten des
landes mecklenburg vorpommern und ich
weiß dass die bearbeitung von
bürgeranliegen kein dienst nach
vorschrift ist es muss viel nachgehakt
und erklärt werden die arbeit erfordert
viel hingabe geduld und ausdauer also
auch dafür im namen meiner fraktion an
den ausschuss dienst vielen dank
lubricht die zahl der petitionen ist um
circa 3.000 auf nunmehr 11.600 deutlich
zurückgegangen es gibt also weniger
menschen die sich mit einer petition an
den bundestag wenden wenn sich bürger
von der politik abwenden ist das ein
alarmsignal denn ich glaube nicht dass
alle zufrieden sind und es keine
probleme in deutschland gibt liegt der
rückgang an der rückläufigen
erwartungshaltung an der politik an der
würde des zugangs oder haben die bürger
im war ja vielleicht auch andere
möglichkeiten genutzt um an ihre
abgeordneten zukommen im gegensatz zu
dieser entwicklung gibt es ein
ungebrochenes interesse an privaten
plattformen games gehört und wir müssen
uns fragen hat eine petition ein
mehrwert für bürger die sie an den
deutschen bundestag richten gegenüber
privaten plattformen im vergangenen jahr
hat der ausschuss inklusive der
überhänge aus dem vorjahr 12.600
petitionen beraten und in diesen
verfahren entscheidungen getroffen in
jedem dritten fall wurde das angebot
zurückgewiesen die hälfte der anlagen
wurde nicht von antaris beraten und nur
in circa vier prozent der verfahren gab
es dann ein wirklich unterstützen das
votum vom ausschuss aber selbst das
heißt nicht dass diese vier prozent der
unterstützten anliegen tatsächlich
umgesetzt werden die voten des
ausschusses lösten dann eine rückantwort
des zuständigen ministeriums aus und oft
heißt es dann wir sehen keinen
handlungsbedarf
das bedeutet wenn sich eine mit einer
petition an den bundestag wenden
bekommt er post aus berlin immerhin das
ist sicher nutzt man eine private
plattform erhält man etwa vielleicht
200.000 zeichner dann hat man mediale
wirkung und spätestens wenn die
unterschriften dann öffentlich übergeben
werden und der jeweilige minister zum
gespräch vorbei kommt dann erreicht man
etwas das sollte uns nachdenklich machen
für unsere arbeit und in vielen fällen
ist es ja tatsächlich in unserem
ausschuss schwer bis unmöglich petenten
zu helfen bei rechtsstaatlichen
möglichkeiten
verwaltungsgerichtsverfahren
ausgeschöpft wurden und auf 2221 gab es
viele solcher petitionen betroffene
wenden sich an uns abgeordnete oft
verzweifelt mit der letzten hoffnung und
wir haben faktisch praktisch keine
möglichkeit zu helfen für solche fälle
hat meine fraktion schon mehrfach auch
in den jüngsten haushaltsverhandlungen
die einrichtung eines härtefallfonds
gefordert den der petitionsausschuss
nutzen kann wenn wir unbillige härten
feststellen dass wurde hier abgelehnt
denken sie bitte noch einmal darüber
nach wir werden in dieser form mit
der frauen die dank steht auch besteht
aus meiner sicht auch darüber hinaus und
unsere wichtigsten forderungen sind
erstens die dauer der verfahren zu
verkürzen zweitens der online-zugang
muss verbessert werden daran wird
gearbeitet aber es muss schnell gehen
drittens die sitzung des
petitionsausschusses sollten
grundsätzlich öffentlich sein viertes
die beratung von petitionen mit
besonders hoher mit zeichnungen zahl
sollten im plenum angemessen beraten
werden um nur einiges zu nennen ich weiß
im koalitionsvertrag findet sich das
bekenntnis zu reformen der petitions
arbeit meine aktionen wird ihre
einladung auch gerne annehmen und sie
daran erinnern kindern
soweit ihnen lautenfeld sie hat das
angesprochen auch im bundestag gibt es
diskussionen wie der ausschuss
aufgewertet während carmen bundestags
präsidentin bärbel basel möchte das auch
norden hatte sommerpause soll es dazu
gespräche geben beate müller gemmeke
spricht jetzt für die bündnisgrünen
der frau präsidentin kolleginnen und
kollegen mit der ampel ist auch ein
frischer wind in den petitionsausschuss
eingezogen wir arbeiten sehr kooperativ
sehr lösungsorientiert wir gehen trotz
politischer unterschiede schritte
aufeinander zu uns geht es nicht darum
ob eine petition zufällig dem
koalitionsvertrag entspricht um sie nur
dann an ein ministerium zu überweisen
und deshalb gibt es bei uns auch nicht
mehr das votum soweit es dem
koalitionsvertrag entspricht ich bin mir
sicher dass wir mit dieser haltung den
anliegen der menschen wirklich gerecht
werden
und kollegen ladendorf sie haben gesagt
wir haben abgelehnt das ist ein vorgeben
sollen oder so was wir haben gerade erst
vor kurzem eine petition die wir lange
lange beraten haben nämlich von herr
noack an die bundespräsidentin
weitergeleitet und genau da
regelungen zu finden wir schauen
wir schauen im petitionsausschuss was
steht hinter der petition darum gibt es
den änderungswunsch weshalb sein
funktioniert ein gesetz in der praxis
nicht gut wo gibt es handlungsbedarf die
forderung der petition muss da nicht
eins zu eins umgesetzt werden es geht
darum die kritik und den denk stoß
anzunehmen mit leben zu füllen ernst zu
nehmen und dem zuständigen ministerium
mit auf den weg zu geben und das
funktioniert in der ampel erstaunlich
gut und deshalb möchte ich auch den
vielen neuen kolleginnen und kollegen
und natürlich auch den alten kolleginnen
und kollegen und natürlich bei unserer
tollen ausschuss vorsitzende martina
stammt wie gehe ich ganz herzlich
bedanken
der jahresbericht zeigt auch noch einmal
dass die menschen vor allem soziale
themen und treiben die themen sind breit
gestreut es geht um die rechte von
beschäftigten um das rentensystem um
unterstützung für menschen mit
behinderung es geht um armut und soziale
sicherheit und wenn es im bereich arbeit
und soziales so viele petitionen gibt
dann müssen wir das auch sehr ernst
nehmen denn hier geht es nicht zuletzt
um den zusammenhalt in unserer
gesellschaft
die menschen
die menschen die sich an den
petitionsausschuss wänden sind entweder
selbst betroffen und brauchen konkrete
hilfe für ihren einzelfall an dem andere
machen ganz konkrete vorschläge wie das
system insgesamt und für alle verbessert
und weiterentwickelt werden kann und
dabei geht es häufig um hartz 4 und
bekannte themen die sanktionen aber auch
um sehr spezielle regelungen
beispielsweise um das sogenannte
zuflussprinzip
auf den ersten blick ist es ein
randthema eine juristische spielerei die
betroffenen fühlen sich aber ungerecht
behandelt und können entscheidungen
einfach nicht nachvollziehen und da ist
auch nicht alles logisch wir nehmen so
was natürlich selbstverständlich mit und
mit dem geplanten bürger geld kriegt es
bald auch tatsächlich eine
parlamentarische chance petition können
also wichtige impulse seien das ist
gelebte demokratie
und genau so muss es sein
und für die cdu csu hat das vorzimmer
ohne burchert und auch simone burkhart
sitzt im petitionsausschuss
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen
trotzdem einer relativ kurzen dauer als
mitglied des petitionsausschusses
habe ich wirklich schon einiges erleben
dürfen es werden sehr bewegende momente
dabei aber auch so manche petition hat
mich wirklich zum kopfschütteln animiert
insgesamt war es eine sehr bereichernde
und eine sehr bürgernahe
praxisnahe tätigkeit die wir alle in
diesem ausschuss leisten sehr geehrte
damen und herren die bedeutung des
petitionsrecht es in unserem rechtsstaat
ist gar nicht hoch genug zu bewerten
das kann ich jetzt schon nach wenigen
monaten zugehörigkeit sagen ich sehe wie
ernsthaft sich alle kolleginnen und
kollegen mit den einzelnen anliegen
befassen und über parteigrenzen hinweg
konstruktiv in den austausch treten ohne
die bevor rufe jetzt sozusagen mit
dieser billigen kaufen mentalität möchte
ich sagen wir diskutieren sache ich hart
in der sache und hitzig und liebe frau
schlampig es gelingt ihnen immer wieder
uns einzufangen und dafür auch
herzlichen dank dafür
[Musik]
und die zahlen sprechen für sich es
wurde schon ganz oft genannt im
berichtszeitraum wurden ganze elf 1667
petition beim deutschen bundestag
eingereicht und es überrascht auch nicht
dass wir davon während der pandemie
2176 petition aus dem bereich gesundheit
haben das bespricht einem anteil von 25
prozent und ich möchte jetzt und hier
die gelegenheit nutzen und an alle
bürgerinnen und bürger appellieren sie
können und sollten bei bedarf von dem
grundrecht nach artikel 17 des
grundgesetzes gebrauch machen dort heißt
es nämlich
verlauf der präsidentin würde ich jetzt
hier zitieren jedermann hat das recht
sich einzeln oder in gemeinschaft mit
anderen schriftlich mit bitten oder
beschwerden an die zuständigen stellen
und an die volksvertretung zu wenden
bei der bearbeitung jeder einzelposition
können wir erkennen welches engagement
von den zuständigen stellen hier
geleistet wird vor allem in der
verwaltung und das wird an den zahlen
deutlich die wir bearbeiten und deshalb
möchte ich auch von meiner fraktion hier
nochmal den dank aussprechen an das
ausschusssekretariat an den ausschuss
dienst an die mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter in den fraktionen und an
alle zuständigen stellen in den
ministerien herzlichen dank dafür und
ein ordentliches und zuverlässiges
petitionsverfahren ist auch ausdruck
einer gelebten demokratie
und ich kann ihnen sagen als
berichterstatterin lernt man viel neues
man erfährt viel über rechtliche
regelungen hintergrund
sachzusammenhänge mit denen man sonst
weniger zu tun hat und über die eigene
berichterstattung hinaus bekommt man ein
gefühl dafür was bewegt die menschen im
land und welche problem konstellation
gibt es hier das ist für mich und für
meine politische arbeit wirklich
wertvoll und eine echte bereicherung
aber auch in digitalen zeiten schafft
das internet der öffentlichkeit und
kommunikationsmöglichkeiten mit den
bürgerinnen bürgern und es hat auch für
für das petitionsverfahren eine riesen
bedeutung heute ist durch die digitalen
prozesse es viel einfacher den fokus auf
ein anliegen zu richten und auch
unterstützen natürlich online dazu zu
gewinnen und über diese digitalen
möglichkeiten der petentin und petenten
haben wir heute natürlich schon vieles
gehört es gibt reformbedarf und dieser
wurde erkannt der erste vorgeschmack auf
die neue internetplattform ist wirklich
sehr vielversprechend und dadurch werden
die petitionsverfahren
effektiver schneller und einfacher
und meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
es kann nicht für jede sonder
konstellation und für jeden einzelfall
die wie in den petitionsausschuss
erleben eine individuelle rechtliche
regelung geben es gibt ja auch keine
vollkaskoversicherung von seiten des
staates das lehne ich entschieden ab
wenn aber eine petition begründet ist
dann ist es mir auch ein persönliches
anliegen die nötige unterstützung eigene
zur verfügung stehenden mitteln zu
leisten
und da möchte ich nun auch meine erste
öffentliche petition kommen es war eine
petition zur erkrankung vom mfs diese
position wurde am 14 februar öffentlich
verhandelt der petent war nach der
verhandlung oder nach der öffentlichen
anhörung enttäuscht über das ergebnis
und über den austausch und für mich wie
auch für die über 50.000 unterstützer
der petition sind nach der anhörung
viele fragen offen auch die erneute
stellungnahme des
bundesgesundheitsministerium zu dieser
sache und zu jeder position ist völlig
unzureichend
und weil es mir gerade bei diesen
sachverhalt ein persönliches anliegen
ist werde ich dieses thema intensiv
weiter begleiten
der potenz fm betroffene leitet an
dieser krankheit und bringt immer wieder
viel kraft auf sich für die betroffenen
stark zu machen ich drücke ihnen hiermit
meine herzlichsten dank dafür aus masse
ihm und einen anderen betroffenen mut
wir werden an diesem thema dranbleiben
im petitionsausschuss und im
gesundheitsausschuss
und sehr geehrte frau
ausschussvorsitzender am ersten juni
habe ich den bestehenden beratungs
betragen bedarf für diese für dieses
thema schriftlich vorgetragen und einen
berichterstatter gespräch dazu beantragt
gestern wurde das gespräch auf nach der
sommerpause terminiert herzlichen dank
dafür dass das jetzt auch so schnell
geklappt hat ich bedanke mich für die
gute zusammenarbeit im ausschuss melden
sie uns bitte immer in der sache lebhaft
geht sich streiten ich denke das
zeichnet uns da wirklich aus vielen dank
für ihre aufmerksamkeit
sagt simone vorhand und wir warten
weiter auf die pressekonferenz von von
der leyen und im shell wenn sie übrigens
in dieser zeit soll bundestagsdebatte
weiterverfolgen können wir übertragen
die bundestagsdebatte weiter auf unserem
kanal auf youtube das heißt das können
sie dann auch machen aber momentan haben
wir ja sowieso hier im deutschen
bundestag
frau präsidentin liebe kollegin sehr
geehrte damen und liebe kollegen
natürlich auch crooner prägte alle
ausschüsse so gut inhaltlich
auch unser tores
inzwischen haben wir uns alle daran
gewöhnt damit zu arbeiten am anfang war
es dennoch ein ungewohntes gefühl vom
heimischen schreibtisch über positionen
zu entscheiden aber corona wie es uns
keine wahl wir mussten digital tagen
wenn es überhaupt etwas positives gab
die krone maßnahmen haben gar
digitalisierung einen ordentlichen schub
gegeben so auch den petitionsausschuss
es gab viele petitionen zu problemen im
zusammenhang mit argwohn abstand gerade
hier war der petitionsausschuss eine
echo kam auch für die stimmung in der
bevölkerung
er zeigt auf welche gruppen zu wenig bei
den hilfsprogrammen der bundesregierung
berücksichtigt wurden hier möchte ich
nun zb die freiberufler solo
selbstständigen sowie kultur und medien
schaffen denn deren tätigkeit auch oft
mit reisen verbunden sind die
reisebeschränkungen haben auch zuviel
familienschicksalen geführt durch die
eigenen petition sichtbar sind
eingereichten petition kronen aber auch
eine große herausforderung für den
tourismus das sieht man im
tourismusausschuss dem ich ebenfalls
angehören
vom petitionsausschuss
profitiere wenn alle für die gesamte
politische arbeit die stellungnahmen aus
den ministerien in verschiedenen
positionen sind sehr qualifiziert an
dieser stelle möchte ich mich nicht nur
bei den mitarbeitern des ausschusses
bedanken sondern das wurde hier auch
schon häufig getan und das mit vollem
recht weiterhin möchte ich auch den
beamten und angestellten in den
ministerien
duncan in einzelfällen wir haben
manchmal eine schnellere beantwortung
wünschenswert aber der arbeitstage
verein für ministerien ist nicht zu
unterschätzen und sehr häufig geben sich
die petition mit den qualifizierten
antworten aus den verschiedenen häusern
schon zufrieden das entlastet uns
abgeordnete und wir können uns um die
petition kümmern deren anliegen eine
gewisse berechtigung haben vielen dank
dafür
bürger die wie ich in der ddr noch die
ddr noch erlebt haben haben ein
besonderes verhältnis zur petition
damals hier ist es nicht petition
sondern eingabe es war die einzige
möglichkeit sich gegen
verwaltungshandeln zu wehren aber hier
haben einige eingaben vor ort doch zu
änderungen von verwaltungsentscheidungen
geführt so bin ich also 86 persönlich
nach berlin gereist und habe im
bürogebäude von ihrer schule gerade
eingabe eingereicht einen
telefonanschluss zu bekommen vier wochen
später hatte ich ihn dann allerdings
nach unglaublich vier jahren des wartens
manchmal wünsche ich mir dass so eine
schnelle bearbeitung heute wirklich ist
ohne vier jahre war das teil im vorfeld
natürlich
auch 2021 haben die petition gezeigt
dass noch nicht alle mochten aus die
mietervereinigung beseitigt sind unser
ausschuss setzt sich daher für
zwangsumsiedlungen
die im gegensatz zu gefängnis opfer
entschädigt wurden dabei geht es den
betroffenen nicht nur um geld sondern
dass ihr leid anerkannt wird und das
unrecht einer breiten öffentlichkeit
bewusst wird beim grenze von 61 wurden
bürger zwangsumgesiedelt
die als nicht politisch zuverlässig
galten im neuen erzwungenen wohnort
waren so oft außenseiter
über die negativ geredet wurde und was
haben die schon ausgefressen hieß es
dann immer besonders müssten natürlich
dann immer die kinder leiden junge
mütter wochen gezwungen ihr kind zur
adoption hat zu geben auch wenn sie sich
nach der friedlichen revolution noch oft
langen weg wieder gefunden haben gab es
nicht immer das erhoffte happy end auch
gibt es hinweise dass in der ddr das in
der ddr kinder von politisch und
politischen personen zur adoption
freigegeben wurden den eltern wurde
gesagt das kind sei verstorben nie
wieder darf so etwas passieren
auch in meinem wahlkreis spricht man
mich an missstände und gesetzesänderung
weil etwas genaueres hinzu in dormagen
ein aktuelles beispiel ist das thema
lärmbelästigung wegen der
umgehungsstraße am ende in ostthüringen
beim total einbau neubau wird der schall
von bahn und strasse agiert als gesamte
belastung bei sanierungs neubau zählt
jede schall belastung als barroso bahn
und straße für sich meine damen und
herren der lärm ist dasselbe nur die
grenzwerte sind unterschiedlich
petition sind meine herzenssache und ich
halte diesen ausschuss für einen ganz
wichtigen ausschuss im bundestag
vielen dank
das war regional hankes erste regel hier
im deutschen bundestag und er hat unter
anderen die lange bearbeitungsdauer
angesprochen im schnitt dauert es und
zwei jahre bis lotionen bearbeitet
werden auch das soll verkürzt werden so
plant ist zumindest bundestags
präsidentin bärbel bas annika klose
spricht jetzt für die spd fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen liebe
zuschauer der petitionsausschuss bietet
allen menschen die möglichkeit und das
recht sich auf direktem wege gehör beim
deutschen bundestag zu verschaffen und
wenn ich sage allen menschen dann heißt
das tatsächlich auch genau dass allen
menschen und zwar unabhängig von ihrem
alter ihrem wohnsitz ihrer nationalität
oder der art des anliegens alle können
sich an uns wenden es ist mir wichtig
dass dieses recht den menschen bekannt
ist und dass sie es nutzen
doch der nun vorgelegte jahresbericht
zum jahr 20 21 zeigt einen rückgang in
der anzahl der eingereichten petition
und das obwohl wir uns in einer pandemie
befanden die jeder und wie vor große
herausforderungen stellt
herausforderungen die gehört werden
mussten und müssen
als abgeordneter aus berlin-mitte freut
es nicht darum besonders dass in berlin
dass berlin das bundesland ist in dem
ihr verhältnis zur einwohner innen teil
die meisten petitionen eingereicht
wurden denn natürlich ist das ein
zeichen von engagement und partizipation
ich wünsche mir dass sowohl in berlin
als auch in ganz deutschland und darüber
hinaus diese form der beteiligung noch
stärker wahrgenommen wird und ich setze
mich dafür ein dass dieser wunsch nicht
unerfüllt bleibt
wird auch bürgerin die sich nicht an den
petitionsausschuss wänden haben häufig
anliegen die gehör finden sollten obwohl
alle menschen das recht haben den
petitionsausschuss in anspruch zu nehmen
fällt auf dass nicht alle in gleichem
maße von diesem recht gebrauch machen
wir sind also diejenigen die wir stärker
erreichen sollten einerseits sind es
frauen die im jahr 20 21 nur ein viertel
der petition eingereicht haben es sind
außerdem menschen mit
migrationshintergrund und es sind
außerdem generell jüngere menschen die
bisher nicht ausreichend erreicht werden
für seine weitere arbeit muss der
petitionsausschuss sich deswegen zum
ziel machen auch sie besser anzusprechen
das hat ist es unerlässlich dass wir
wege nutzen und petitionen
alltagstauglicher und zeitgemäßer zu
machen so kann die verbreitung und mit
zeichnungen der petition über soziale
medien eine entscheidende rolle sein
einnehmen und auch das angebot von
informationen einfacher sprache und in
fremdsprachen werden wir damit werden
wir mehr menschen erreichen können als
bisher letztlich ist das beste argument
für das einreichen einer petition aber
wenn deutlich wird dass sich darüber
tatsächlich ein spürbarer effekt auf das
politische geschehen in diesem land
ergibt deshalb ist es unabdingbar dass
der petitionsausschuss einen höheren
stellenwert bekommt und die mehr
aufmerksamkeit zuteil wird
die verantwortung dafür eine
wahrnehmbare
aufmerksamkeit aufwertung seiner arbeit
herbeizuführen liegt aber nicht
ausschließlich beim petitionsausschuss
selbst sondern auch beim deutschen
bundestag in seiner gesamtheit
ich bin daher sehr dankbar dafür dass
die koalitionsfraktionen daran arbeiten
wollen das petitionsverfahren zu stärken
und das sieht das vorhaben dem
entsprechenden koalitionsvertrag
aufgenommen haben der plan petitionen
nahe zukunft auch in ausschüssen und
hier im plenum beraten zu können den
begrüße ich sehr denn sie ist rückt die
anliegen der bürgerinnen ein großes
stück näher und die aufmerksam und gibt
ihnen die aufmerksamkeit die sie
verdienen mehr an die aufwärtsrisiken
petition sind nicht nur von großem wert
für diejenigen die sie inhaltlich
betreffen uns abgeordneten ermöglichen
zellen unmittelbaren kontakt zu den
themen die die bürgerinnen beschäftigen
sie geben uns die chance sowohl einen
persönlichen einblick in die einzelnen
ligen zu kriegen und sie im detail zu
verstehen als auch die themen zu spüren
die tausende von menschen bewegen in
meinem eigenen zuständigkeitsbereich im
ausschuss das sind die themen arbeit und
soziales sowie außenpolitik wird das
besonders deutlich von individuellen
problemen mit dem rentenbescheid oder
der anrechnung auf das arbeitslosengeld
2 rechter spektrum bis zu themen mit
globaler relevanz wie bewaffnete
konflikte und humanitäre krisen allesamt
verdienst dieser anliegen ernst genommen
zu werden und gewissenhaft behandelt zu
werden als
mitglied des petitionsausschusses bin
ich auch sehr froh darüber dass dies
hierzu einen beitrag leisten zu können
und ich bin froh zu wissen dass die
angehörigen des ausschusses insgesamt
sich diesem anspruch an die
gewissenhaftigkeit ihrer arbeit sich
diesen anspruch äußerst zu herzen nehmen
einfach gesagt möchte auch ich an dieser
stelle an den ausschuss dienst
aussprechen da er die grundlage für die
arbeit im petitionsausschuss
ausschuss schafft und diese zu arbeit
wirklich unabdingbar für diese arbeit
ist
zu guter letzt möchte ich doch ein punkt
agenten der mir besonders wichtig ist so
gut wie den zugang zum
petitionsausschuss auch stärken und so
aus gebe ich sich dieser ausschuss auch
mit den anliegen auseinandersetzt können
wir nur dann abhilfe schaffen wenn die
bitten und beschwerden der bürgerinnen
über den ausschuss hinaus gehört werden
insbesondere ist es hier an der
bundesregierung hin zu hören und tätig
zu werden ich appelliere daher an die
bundesregierung nicht den einfachsten
weg im umgang mit den überwiesenen
petition zu nehmen sondern konstruktiv
und mit nachdruck daran zu arbeiten
lösungen für die anliegen zu finden die
der petitionsausschuss als sprachrohr
für all jene menschen die sich an den
wänden an die bundesregierung
herantreten
schließlich kann sich nur so nicht nur
abhilfe für das beklagte problem
geschaffen werden sondern auch das
vertrauen in unsere demokratie gestärkt
werden vielen dank
die nächste rednerin in der debatte ist
zwang ihr henrike michaelsen fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen
die möglichkeit eine petition an den
bundestag zu richten ist zu recht ein
grundrecht so können sich alle menschen
in diesem land unabhängig von alter oder
wahlrecht an der demokratie beteiligen
sie können aber auch ihre sorgen und
nöte an uns richten die liste der
petition 20 21 ist beeindruckend
beindruckend lang beeindruckend
vielfältig beeindruckend engagiert und
wenn man sich einen überblick verschafft
über die themen dann sieht man gerade im
rückblick sehr gut welche themen die
gesellschaft bewegt haben damit können
wir als mitglieder des ausschusses wenn
wir aufmerksam genug sind aus den
eingehenden petitionen eben häufig mehr
ablesen als die einzelmeinung gerade die
petitionen aus öffentlichen sitzung
zeigen uns dass ein bestimmtes thema
viele menschen gleichzeitig bewegt wir
sehen daran gesellschaftliche stimmung
manchmal brennpunkte wir können erkennen
welche debatten im land geführt werden
und wir tragen mit unseren worten dazu
bei dass diese gesellschaftlichen
diskussionen eingang finden in die
parlamentarischen debatten und in die
arbeit der bundesregierung
dass sie eingang finden in gesetze und
in die rahmenbedingungen mit dem wir das
zusammenleben in deutschland gestalten
wir nehmen aber natürlich die themen
auch mit in die arbeit in unserem
fachausschüssen so dass die petitionen
auch über die voten hinaus politischer
entscheid auf politische entscheidungen
einwirken
dafür ist die arbeit ich wollte
eigentlich vor heute sagen und ich hoffe
dass es weiter geht die zusammenarbeit
im petitionsausschuss zentral
als neues mitglied erlebe ich das
miteinander im petitionsausschuss ganz
an als an vielen anderen stellen im
system bundestag
die debatten sind auch hier
leidenschaftlich manchmal ein bisschen
verrückt aber immer an der sache
interessiert und wirklich geleitet von
dem bemühen die anliegen der petenten
nicht nur ernst zu nehmen sondern diese
auch in gute quoten zu überführen denen
möglichst viele mitglieder des
ausschusses zustimmen können diese
zusammenarbeit
diese zusammenarbeit und ich wollte es
wirklich über die meisten
fraktionsgrenzen hinweg zu nennen und
hoffe dass ein teil dieser debatte von
heute nicht für die weitere
ausschussarbeit repräsentativ ist denn
sie ist für mich ein großer lichtblick
im politischen alltagsgeschäft und so
freue ich mich sehr auf die arbeit im
petitionsausschuss in den nächsten
monaten und jahren wir werden in dieser
wahlperiode das petitionsrecht stärken
damit es für noch mehr menschen
einfacher wird das grundrecht auf
beteiligung an der demokratie
wahrzunehmen ich bin gespannt auf die
themen die die menschen an uns
herantreten werden und ich freue mich
auf gute zusammenarbeit für die menschen
und ihre anliegen in diesem wichtigen
ausschuss vielen dank
es waren für michael sind war das für
bündnis 90 die grünen im deutschen
bundestag und im martina engelhardt kopf
spricht jetzt für die unionsfraktionen
auch solist mitglied im
petitionsausschuss
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen und vor allem
sehr geehrte bürgerinnen und bürger auch
ich bin in dieser wahlperiode nicht nur
neu gewähltes mitglied des deutschen
bundestages sondern auch neues mitglied
im petitionsausschuss
in dieser kurzen zeit habe ich großen
respekt vor der arbeit des ausschusses
und insbesondere auch vor die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern des
ausschuss dienstes gewonnen was pensum
was sie zu bewältigen haben ist wirklich
unglaublich im letzten jahr wurden es
wurde heuer vorher bereits mehrmals
genannt und elf 1667 petitionen
eingereicht das sind knapp 32 editionen
pro tag und wirklich jede eingabe wird
geprüft und bearbeitet bevor sie uns was
auch geordnete überhaupt zugeht aber
dieser hohe aufwand lohnt sich denn er
ist das grundrecht der bürgerinnen und
bürger in unserem land nämlich dass sie
sich direkt und uns und die vertreter im
parlament wenden können genau das macht
die arbeit in diesem ausschuss auch so
spannend und abwechslungsreich
die vielfältigen großen und kleinen
bitten aber auch beschwerden ideen die
eingaben spiegeln letztendlich das
meinungsbild der bürgerinnen und bürger
auch wieder und geben uns probleme ein
ganz feiner seismograph der uns wieder
spielt was die bürgerinnen und bürger
bewegt aber auch welche sorgen und nöte
sie haben bis hin zur völligen
problemlösungen die aufgezeigt werden in
mehr als der hälfte der petitionen des
letzten jahres haben sich petenten mit
ganz persönlichen anliegen an den
deutschen bundestag gewandt es sind
gerade diese
corona bedingt aber auch fragen der
sozialen sicherungssysteme und vieles
mehr
die die menschen berühren bewegen oft
zur förderung auch sorgen und direkt an
uns weitergegeben werden ich war wie
deshalb zu behaupten dass die nähe zu
den bürgerinnen und bürgern besonders in
diesem ausschuss zur zum ausdruck zur
bedeutung kommt
was ich an dieser stelle auch nochmals
betonen möchte ist das sich wirklich
jeder egal also welches roller kinder
erwachsene welche nationalität welche
staatsangehörigkeit mit einer petition
an den deutschen bundestag wenden kann
ganz egal ob postalisch elektronisch
über das online portal
ich ermutige an dieser stelle
ausdrücklich noch einmal alle
bürgerinnen und bürger auch von diesem
recht von diesen unterschiedlichen
möglichkeiten gebrauch zu machen im
petitionsausschuss haben wir die
möglichkeit ihre anliegen von den
fachministerien prüfen zu lassen
wir können wissenschaftler und gut auch
der beauftragung anhören oder uns direkt
vor ort ein bild von der jeweiligen
situation machen ihre petition können
wir den zuständigen gremien überweisen
wo sie im weiteren
gesetzgebungsverfahren berücksichtigung
finden können die möglichkeiten sind
sehr weitreichend petitionsverfahren
können sie aufwendig sein aber alles
sinn denn ziel der sachgerechten
bewertung der jeweiligen anliegen der
bürgerinnen und bürger so konnte im
vergangenen jahr zum beispiel eine
petition zur stärkung des ehrenamts
erfolgreich abgeschlossen werden hier
forderte die petentin dass insbesondere
ehrenamtliche aufwandsentschädigungen
nicht beim elterngeld angerechnet werden
im rahmen der neuregelung des
bundeselterngeld- und elternzeitgesetz
konnten hier verbesserungen erzielt
werden
einiges an petitionswesen die sich aber
aus meiner sicht noch deutlich
verbessern angesprochen wurde die online
plattform diese muss dringend zeitgemäß
erweitert werden ich denke aber auch an
apps wie vor an ganz klar dass es
künftig auch möglich ist im rahmen der
bundestag app für alle bürgerinnen und
bürger hier auch petitionen einzureichen
also ganz niederschwellige einfache
angebote um möglichst viele bürgerinnen
bürger jung und alt anzusprechen damit
diese direkt ihre anliegen auch
weitergeben können
entscheidend wird aber und dieser stelle
natürlich auch sein dass wir diese neuen
online forma diese verbesserungen zügig
umsetzen und wir hatten hier zu bereiten
die ersten arbeitsgespräche mit vielen
ideen für eine sehr gute
weiterentwicklung dieser möglichkeiten
ähnliches betrifft aber auch die
bearbeitung positionen ich denke an die
akten ich war eingangs schon etwas
irritiert aus stapel und akten und
papierberge in mein büro gekommen sind
auch das ist aus meiner sicht nicht mehr
zeitgemäß wir brauchen die e-akte wir
brauchen die möglichkeit hier auch
online diese vorgänge zu bearbeiten das
schafft unterm strich auch wieder mehr
effizienz schnelligkeit in der zeit der
bearbeitung dieser anliegen auch hier
müssen wir schneller müssen wir besser
werden
ein entscheidender punkt an dieser
stelle wenn es um die bearbeitungszeit
und schnelligkeit geht ist letztendlich
auch dass wir uns alle zusammenreißen
dass petitionen nicht häufig wieder
geschoben und vertraut werden auch ich
habe mir die zahlen des berichtes sehr
deutlich angeschaut und festgestellt
dass gerade in den vergangenen monaten
die ersten eingehenden positionen häufig
geschoben werden 27 wurden vertrag der
ersten 100 eingegangenen positionen
vergleich zur letzten wahlperiode elf
positionen auch hier müssen wir
schneller besser werden damit die
bürgerinnen und bürger schnelle zeit
neue rückmeldungen auch bekommen und wir
gute lösungen finden
ich bedanke mich abschließend
insbesondere bei allen kolleginnen und
kollegen des ausschusses dienstes die
wirklich unglaubliches leisten ich hatte
die zuarbeit eingangs angesprochenen
aber auch bei allen kolleginnen und
kollegen des petitionsausschusses auch
ich erlebe die arbeiter diskussionen als
sehr vertrauensvoll offen oft auch ein
leidenschaftlicher
austausch zum wohl der sache für die
jeweils persönlichen anliegen und gerade
in puncto persönliche anliegen es
handelt sich oft und sehr vertrauliche
informationen und daten die bürgerinnen
und bürger uns weitergeben aufgrund
dessen kann es in der zukunft leider
nicht möglich sein dass petitionen immer
öffentlich auch behandelt werden das
würde hier doch vielen
persönlichkeitsrechten widersprechen
liegen deshalb müssen wir ja sonst sie
für den zehn unterscheiden herzlichen
dank alles gute und gottes zu lernen
martina engel hat kopf war das hat hier
noch einmal auch angesprochen damit eine
petition öffentlich würden muss sie
bestimmten kriterien entsprechen nicht
alle tun das selbstverständlich und
letzter redner in dieser debatte ist
erik von malottki
kolleginnen und kollegen
bürger die sprachliche herkunft des
wortes petition verdeutlicht sehr
eindrücklich den vielfältigen charakter
von petitionen die wir hier im deutschen
bundestag bearbeiten das lateinische
wort bio bedeutet bitte wie auch
verlangen wir halten also petitionen die
er als bitte gestellt werden eine
sichere überquerung einer straße durch
die einrichtung einer ampel an einer
bundesstraße oder die überprüfung eines
als ungerecht empfundenen
ablehnungsbescheid dass eine behörde wir
halten ebenso petition die er eine
forderung erheben
zb die intensivierung für die bemühungen
für eine bessere verkehrswende oder das
einfordert und zusätzlichen mitteln für
die digitalisierung an unseren schulen
diese beiden typen von petitionen die
bitten und die forderung sind
gleichwertig wichtig für den
demokratischen charakter unserer
petitionswesen wir sind als abgeordnete
petitionsausschuss naja doppelrolle als
kümmerer aber auch als ansprechpartnerin
ansprechpartner für die forderung der
bürger und bürgerinnen in unserem land
aber warum ist diese arbeit wichtig weil
die petition für den demokratischen
charakter des bundestages und für unsere
demokratie unbedingt benötigen sie sind
unsere demokratische lebensversicherung
gesetze haben lücken berücksichtigen
nicht alle perspektiven
behörden unterlaufen fehler und menschen
in unserem land haben für die vielen
probleme und herausforderungen häufig
die besseren ideen und lösungen als die
ministerialbürokratie aber auch öfter
als wir fachpolitikerin und
fachpolitiker ich möchte deswegen den
petenten und petenten danken denn sie
leisten einen entscheidenden beitrag für
unsere demokratie
mein dank gilt ebenso als dem
beschäftigtem ausschusssekretariat die
mitarbeiter mit arbeiten des
bundestagsbüros und in den fraktionen
sowie meinen engagierten kolleginnen und
kollegen aus dem petitionsausschuss
ich kann mich deshalb auch meinen
vorrednern und verriet anschließend wenn
es um die notwendigen reform bedarf das
petitionswesen es geht damit unsere
demokratischen lebensversicherung noch
besser funktioniert muss das
petitionswesen intuitiver barrierefreier
kommunikativer und vor allem digitaler
werden wir brauchen dafür auch endlich
einen härtefallfonds um den fällen
unkompliziert zu helfen bei der wir
bisher keine eindeutige haushalterisch
oder gesetzliche möglichkeit haben
ich möchte an dieser stelle einmal
konkret an hat eine petition
verdeutlichen was petitionen leisten
können nach der wende haben sich die
bürgerinnen und bürger der kleinen insel
ummanz bei rüben die berechtigte
hoffnung gemacht im rahmen von vermögens
zuordnung zu erfahren ehemals
volkseigene grundstücke auf der insel zu
erwerben familien die diese flächen seit
vielen jahrzehnten gemeinschaftlich
bewirtschaftet und bewohnt haben wollten
sich nach der wende ein stück heimat und
sicherheit schaffen wie in so vielen
fällen in dieser zeit wurden versprechen
der politik nicht gehalten und die
familie von hans konnten die grundstücke
nicht erwerben um diese ungerechtigkeit
und die damit verbundenen
ungereimtheiten aufzudecken haben sie
sich in einer interessengemeinschaft
zusammengeschlossen und auch mit einer
petition an den deutschen bundestag
gewandt das anliegen der familien von
romans steht dabei exemplarisch für die
unzähligen unrechts erfahrung in
ostdeutschland nach der wende diese
unrechts erfahrung das gefühl nicht
gesehen zu werden sind heute in
ostdeutschland der nähe hohen für
frustration und politikverdrossenheit
sie sind auch das einfallstor für
rechtsradikale die diese enttäuschung
nutzen wollen um unsere demokratie zu
schädigen ich freue mich deshalb sehr
dass wir eine ob leute runde vereinbart
haben dem anliegen der familie von omans
in einem ersten einem der ersten vor ort
termine des neu gewählten
petitionsausschusses nachzugehen wir
werden gemeinsam prüfen was wir jetzt
noch für die familien von uns bewegen
können aber wir zeigen und durch um so
besucht vor allen dingen dass wir sie
und ihr anliegen sehen
wir zeigen dass wir uns kümmern dass wir
uns überhaupt dass wir uns überhaupt als
abgrund das kind gemeinsam versuchen ist
genau diese form des respekts und der
anerkennung auf die so viele menschen
gerade in ostdeutschland so lange
gewartet haben all dies kann das
petitionswesen des bundestages leisten
und auch deshalb ist es die
demokratische lebensversicherung unserer
arbeit ich würde es geben möchte jetzt
noch auf zwei dinge eingehen die die
kollegen und kolleginnen der debatte
vorgebracht haben zu der debatte
zwischen herrn barth und vorwort ich
habe mein eindruck als neue abgeordnete
ist dass der petitionsausschuss wirklich
sehr wenig durch parteipolitische
debatten geprägt ist und ich würde mir
wünschen dass das so bleibt wir können
vielleicht gerne auch noch ein schritt
in die richtige richtung machen
zum herrn brandes von der afg richtig
eins sagen ich finde es immer wichtig
dass worte und taten übereinstimmen sie
haben gesagt dass wir als
regierungskoalition dinge die uns nicht
passt in unsere ideologie nicht
entsprechen ablehnen sie haben in der
letzten sitzung des petitionsausschusses
eine petition abgelegt wo es um den
besseren schutz von institutionen und
menschen vor rechtsextremer gewalt geht
sie widersprechen dem was ihre ideologie
widerspricht und deswegen zeigt das dass
ihre worte hier nicht konsistent sind
aber was mich noch mehr geld ist sie
haben auch direkte demokratie haben
direkte demokratie und volksentscheide
angesprochen sie sehen jemanden vorsicht
der zwei bürgerbegehren in mecklenburg
vorpommern mit mehr als 14.000
unterschriften mitinitiiert hat die fdp
fraktion im kreistag landkreis rostock
hat dieses bürgerbegehren
abgelehnt und hat dafür gesorgt dass
kein bürgerentscheid stattfindet in den
landkreis mecklenburgische seenplatte
höre ich ähnliches von der fdp-fraktion
deswegen ärgert mich das maßlos wenn sie
einerseits sagen sie ihnen zu den
volksentscheide wichtig um konkreten
politischen handelns tun sie genau das
gegenteil
und zum schluss noch ein thema die das
zeigt dass petition nicht nur kümmern
und ansprechbar sein bedeutet sondern
uns im besten fall auch zum handeln und
umsetzen bringt bereits in den
vergangenen wahlperioden gab es
petitionen die auf die prekären
bedingungen der fahrradfahrer beim
deutschen bundestag aufmerksam gemacht
haben heute können die beschäftigten
nach erfolgreichem arbeitskampf und die
nötigen rückenwind aus dem bundestag
stolz darauf dass sein dass ab oktober
einen teich vertrag bekommen
zu diesem erfolg habe auch die
eingereichten petitionen einen beitrag
geleistet sie haben
abgeordneten dazu verpflichtet dazu
verpflichtet mit dem ziel uns mit dem
anliegen der fahren und fahren
auseinanderzusetzen kollegin sie werden
dann zum schluss gekommen die kommt zum
schluss liebe bürgerinnen bürgern geben
4 und zweiter diesen druck geben wir uns
weiter rückenwind bei anliegen die ihm
wichtig sind aber das herz auch gegen
wünschen würden kollegen sie mit unserer
arbeit nicht einverstanden sind davon
lebt unsere demokratie und das
bürokratische lebensversicherung im
deutschen bundestag vielen dank
[Applaus]